discrétion absolue à la mairie de beaune
depuis la mise en examen d'un insulino
de sa femme et de sa fille il aura fallu
attendre la fin de journée pour entendre
l'ancien député il clame son innocence
et celle de sa famille comprend toujours
pas pourquoi il ya cette posture brutale
je peux rien j'ai mal vécu voilà c'est
tout on épouse et ma fille ont bien
travaillé ma femme dans ma permanence de
bonnes j'ai 200 témoignages qui peuvent
en attester on va le faire d'ailleurs
et puis bien sûr ma fille l'assemblée
nationale avec mon autre collaborateur
le maire de beaune a été mis en examen
pour détournement de fonds publics par
dépositaire de l'autorité publique et
blanchiment le magistrat instructeur a
considéré qu'il y avait des indices
graves et concordants à son encontre
il est soupçonné d'avoir perçu des
indemnités destinés à rémunérer des
attachés parlementaires et de les avoir
détourné à des fins personnelles que
veut défendre cette procédure j'ai
décidé de faire appel d'ailleurs parce
que celui-ci combat qu'il faut mener et
c'est dans mon tempérament pour défendre
la famille mon action l'image d'un
territoire au cip delannoy et tout un
territoire qui en effet d'atteindre chez
les républicains sa famille politique on
se dit extrêmement surpris et on met en
avant la présomption d'innocence pour
les adversaires politiques de l'ancien
député des questions se posent sur les
conséquences à tirer de cette mise en
examen
alain suguenot et lui seul devrait en
tirer les conséquences
à lui de déterminer s'ils peuvent rester
maire de beaune président de
l'agglomération dans ces conditions là
on suit au contraire préfèrent sont
dégagés pour mieux assurer sa défense
pour alain suguenot pas question de
mettre entre parenthèses ses mandats il
souhaite prouver son innocence tout en
défendant son territoire